a San Francisco startup launched this
week and it is trying to disrupt the
nearly 600 billion dollar grocery
industry on online retailer brand 'less
sells everything from organic peanut
butter to fluoride free toothpaste and
cooking knives and all of its products
cost only $3 the company sells around
200 household and food items and says it
cuts out supermarkets and traditional
marketing in order to bring savings
directly to customers brand lists
co-founders ito Leffler and Tina Sharkey
are with us good morning good morning
you say the system is broken in what way
well the way in which goods are bought
and sold in this country are broken in
that CPG companies don't actually have
consumers their customers are the stores
so the products are made in the
factories they then go through lots of
inefficiencies to actually get to that
market and by the time it gets to you
you're paying so much markup that we've
decided to cut out of the process when
you say CPG the consumer packaged goods
industry so the products by which you
know things like mugs or tomato sauce or
shampoos or salad dressings all the
things that we use every day all the
things that we love that are part of our
everyday lives
if you actually knew what those things
cost versus what you paid for them my
partner says people would be rioting in
the streets we've become
oh I'm sorry we'll become accustomed to
paying for value where does a $3 factor
and it seems too good to be true well
for us it all came across from better
student customer and the $3.00 was about
simplicity we wanted people to
understand just how easy it was to shop
across an entire line without having to
pay what we call a brand tax and it's
been incredible since we launched people
in over 42 states have actually gone on
to Brenna's come and made a purchase and
the number one thing they keep telling
us was how delightful it feels that it
was so simple for them to buy what about
shipping how do you get these products
so we have two distribution centres one
on the west coast and one in the Midwest
and from the time we process your order
it'll be two days or less to get to you
and your first order
shockingly I'll let you guess the
shipping cost is $3
but it's free shipping if you buy the
membership if you buy the membership for
Bmore not only do we donate 10 meals to
feeding America who is feeding the
hungry but every time you check out
we'll give 2 meals and shipping is free
for a $48 shopping cart everybody who
shops on bread list calm when they check
out we will donate a meal to feeding
America who is actually trying to help
close the hunger gap because we know
that even at $3 there are certain people
who can't afford that I can think of two
major ketchup brands right out there
that we've all grown up with I prefer
one over the other I won't say it on
television that's because I like that
brand why are you so convinced that
people will issue the brands that
they've grown up with and continue to
love at $3 it's quite an easy there's no
real barrier to entry to try what we've
done is actually compiled we took every
ketchup on the market and we actually
tested it across beta testers people
that were coming in and trying and our
team of incredible curators chose the
ones that people loved the most and I
think you'll you know you're fitting
that Millennials are less brand loyal
than one like myself well not only are
we betting on that but 78% of
Millennials have said they don't want to
buy the products that they grew up with
they don't want their parents government
they don't want their parents
institutions and they don't want to go
with the brands they don't represent
their values they want to eat organic
they want to eat natural they want to
work with a company that's socially
responsible they want the transparency
and so Brad lists is definitely a brand
but brownness is reimagining what it
means to be a brand based on
authenticity based on building a
community with the people it serves and
based on transparency and so for first
time head of households 80% of the
babies that are born in this country
today are born to millennial households
so people who are setting up their
college dorm rooms people who are
setting up their first apartments people
who are buying for their families they
are very open to discovering brands that
represent their values there there is a
whole lot happening in the grocery
business right now Amazon's buying Whole
Foods what do you think of that I think
it's awesome I think that country yeah I
think it's fantastic
why the more people are aware of the
natural organic space for us the more
people are aware of the fact that better
shouldn't cost more and in actual fact
for us nothing really changed when that
news came for us those products of the
products that they still are still going
to be there what we've done which is
very different is we've edited down the
assortment today at brown was calm
you'll find hundreds of items versus the
millions of items that you can find
across whether it's Amazon or the 3040
thousand you can find at Whole Foods and
we've made it easier for people to shop
which is really unique exactly the
simplicity of our labeling system the
simplicity of our price point the
simplicity of choice is actually
liberating people because at the end of
the day at brand 'less we really want
people to go out and live more and brand
less not worry about the false narrative
that is on every package at every 299
362 428 and for $3 why not take that our
environment sharky thank you so much for
joining us thank you